[Music]
so let's flash back to childhood just to
paint a picture for folks because people
who have seen your highlight videos like
my god this guy's a savage machine
but let's go back and perhaps
if you wouldn't mind just describe a bit
your childhood and what you were like as
a child
because i had no
knowledge of this until i started doing
research for this conversation but if
you could just describe yourself as a
kid
i think that would be helpful for
setting the stage
when i was born i came out apparently
full with eczema but that went away
and then at four years old i contracted
rheumatic fever
which was the best of the two because it
was either so for leukemia or that so
thankfully it was that i took four
months in the hospital and then when i
was six years old we moved to a village
and that's when my eczema came back
together with severe asthma now my x-men
was really bad i had to wear gloves long
sleeves turtlenecks because i had it in
my neck i was a leper in school that's
what they called me hey aleppo watch out
you don't scratch if i would do this
watch out your ears don't fall off you
know constantly there i was bullied on a
daily basis
but you know when i was 12 i saw we were
on a vacation in france and i saw this
movie enter the dragon it was 17 years
and older to get in but my brother and i
we found a way to sneak in for free and
we were too young for the movie and
that's where i saw bruce lee
and boy that that was it i realized that
if i would be like that guy because he
was also a skinny guy i was a skinny guy
because of my ass but i had these
horrible ass but thanks
then the building would probably stop
because then i could defend myself so it
took me two years to convince my parents
to uh to start martial arts and then
after two years they just they gave up
because that was every day i would ask
them and finally they broke they say
okay just just go and i was fortunate to
um live next to uh two beautiful
neighbor girls and one of the girls was
dating the coolest guy in town xavier
xavier that's how you pronounce it in
holland and and he took me onto a swing
he was always helping me a little bit
because i had these things with birds i
was always in the trees i was swinging
trees but i had these birds that came
pick me up from school i mean they were
so tame they would always sit on my
shoulder wherever i went even in the
shower it was amazing
and he brought me to the adult taekwondo
classes
and within months i started beating some
of the adults of course not the black
belts but i started dropping big guys
and i overheard this guy talking about
me in the dressing room man did you see
that kid boss he dropped jack with a
figure spinning back kick to the head
whoa everybody laughing but that kid has
a lot of talent you know and as a kid
when you only hear bad things about you
when suddenly people start talking good
things about you you tend to listen to
the adults
and that led to the first street fight
the biggest bully in my school shacky
was his name
again i was riding my bicycle on the
street and there he came with six seven
of his buddies and
hey leper whatever he was screaming and
this time i shouted something back
and i heard him laugh i looked back as
sure as they started to chase me and i
told myself this is it i'm not gonna do
it anymore so i put my bike on the stand
on the sidewalk
they came surrounding me with the bikes
i always have to laugh about it because
in the movies this is like in the scene
at night
they do it with with cars and the
headlights are the lighting for the
fight you know but this
was young kids
and then shaki started pushing his chest
to me and challenging me telling me that
i had to hit him
so i did and then i realized that the
bullets weren't really that strong it
took one punch which is weird by the way
because i was doing taekwondo which is
90 kicking
so i knocked them out one punch nose was
broke that was a problem because now the
police was called and they showed up at
my mom and dad's doorstep and that
verified you know you see they always
thought that martial arts was violent so
i have to in in protection of my parents
i never told them i was bullied my mom
had a lot of trouble with me every night
i had to be
mummified as what we call it you know uh
creams and cortisones and put a red me
all around the whole family would send
in old bed sheets which you would wrap
up to bandages and then in the middle of
the night i would scratch it off because
it would itch so bad she had to do it
again so she had so much work with me i
never wanted to bother with her that i
was bullied because i'm pretty sure that
my dad would have known i don't think he
would have said take him off i i believe
he would have said keep him on there
because this is good for him so but
that's that's where everything came from
because then i realized wait a minute
that was easy you know so now i went
after the bullies it always blew i
literally made a list i went every
single one of them adam and other kids
in school who got bullied guess who took
care of that problem you know now i was
the bully the bully guy i took care of
all the bullies though
and that was it my mom and dad they took
me off what i said from taekwondo but
then when i was 20 i moved out of the
house immediately i started doing karate
not re of realizing it was not full
contact
so then i started thai boxing within six
months and then within three months i
started competing thai boxing and one
thing led to another and bada bing bada
boom now i'm here talking to you
now here you are
what do you make of the birds i actually
want to hear a little bit more about
that that's like saint francis of assisi
how did that happen or how do you
explain that i had no friends everybody
thought that was contagious so my time
was spending in the trees i was three
four hours a day in the forest we had a
forest the front of our home we had a
big forest and i was always climbing
trees i could literally coat throughout
the whole forest
and maybe had to go four or five times
down from tree top to treetop i would
swing which came in handy with bullies
if they started to chase me i just
climbed the tree and then they climbed
it through it i started swinging to the
other tree that the bullies tried to do
it on one guy and a big guy one time he
fell down
and his head next to a big rock
and that of course they got out and
suddenly everybody nobody wanted to
chase me anymore so yeah that was it and
that was my contact also with birds i
always was mesmerized with birds
and i found this nest
from uh oh what do you call them here a
jackdaw that's what you call them here a
cow is in dutch
and i i i took one out i knew i had to
do it with gloves because if you put a
human scent on it then they might push
the other ones out so i had this plastic
glove that i went and took one out and
now you become the dad you know so you
start feeding it and it's amazing man
it's
it's so cool because they
you're there for the first flight i mean
every time they go down they crash they
crash they're like steve austin the six
million dollar man on the moon right but
now that's not because there's one day
that he goes and he goes
and he starts going up
and they're so excited to start i
perhaps start screaming and
that was the sound i used to make and
wherever i was he would pick me up from
school this guy he would know in what
room i was
and then just uh he was sitting in front
of the teacher got really angry because
he was constantly ah he would see me in
the class and then afterwards he would
sit on my steering wheel for my bicycle
or on my shoulder he was always with me
wow
you